[Music]
in crazy trial news submitted by ratite
de los Patos and I just spit all over
your computer what does that mean what
does that mean rats gets bats it's a rat
with two feet
Davalos but that was like ratatouille he
knows how to cook no I think they just
made it right
Oh Hector Salamanca what's rapper I mean
that's I mean that's the same I mean
what's what least we know what's the
saying
what's that bass pedal rat Rattus pedal
paletas you just said a rat but that's
time a gang member was shot in court
after tallying a witness with a pen shot
in court so it's by a cop yeah cuz he
was trying to attack a witness with the
pen Wow [ __ ] Marshall was this a
high-level case so it was so they were
in court because this person is the one
I got shot he was he was in court after
being one of 17 people named in a twenty
nine count racketeering indictment that
was filed in 2000 Rico come on Rico bud
got on racketeering and Rico the coolest
thing to say together racketeering is
such a cool name it's like one of the
crimes you want to get caught for what
are you in here for racketeering so what
exactly is racketeering because I think
it's the person that holds the tennis
rackets I don't know but it sounds like
it's a lot of different illicit
businesses so it could it could range
from like like I guess selling stolen
merchandise they're siphoning
huh you're you're a bad on entrepreneur
all been a lot of illicit crimes it's
usually associated with organized crime
yeah
this is organized class yeah yeah but
it's like it's like a conglomerate of
like a lot of different bad businesses
it's not like one thing like this
specific case the gang members were
being accused of conspiracy assault
robbery and weapons offenses and so
that's why the marshals over there it's
all like damn what kind of court cases
are gonna be marshals and that their
racketeering then doesn't much less if
you're tired of that [ __ ] dude yeah I do
think of tennis when I hear a
racketeering yeah yeah so this guy CL
Anglo 25 years old from so he was from
the Crips gained a ton Tongan Crips Oh
our Polynesian brethren yeah oh is this
in California or this happened in Utah
okay they're actually really prevalent
out there yeah there's a lot of yeah
tongue and Crips Salt Lake City
Polynesian gangs Lee yeah I can crazy
they came from like Long Beach and all
that and then because there's a lot of I
think Mormon Polynesians so yeah they
brought that thug life up to salt would
like all go to church yeah that makes
sense cuz it because I feel like like
the opposite always happens so it's like
you have a bunch of Mormons it's like of
course you're gonna have like all that
pressure to be Mormon like there's gonna
be the opposite that's why in those
areas you always see like the highest
amount of weird porn oh yeah I mean it's
like you got to be perfect Mormon guy
it's like well I don't want to be
perfect I'm so restrained like Sheikh
Karl
yeah yeah like he had maybe that was
like all that pressure that made him
want to jack off to that camera man yeah
yeah yeah yeah then I'm probably like
the most innocent person in the world
because I don't have pressures which by
the way mr. Shay Carl I didn't think it
was that big of a deal he just jacked
off what do you do jack off to a cowgirl
eject after camera and he like was he
was talk talking dirty to her
that's like normal behavior yeah that's
what that's what they get paid for those
the dirty talk yeah oh wait wait
he was talking about wanting to [ __ ]
button stuff yeah what did he ever do it
but it wasn't like did the reason why
I'm not saying that it's like it's not
right if you're married
that's normal single man behavior I say
this though I don't think it's right if
you're in a relationship okay well hold
on hold on a [ __ ] second let me get
let me back this guy up real quick all
right the only way I'm not saying it's
okay it wasn't the biggest deal if
people make like he was cheating on her
because her sole purpose that cam girl
is to get clients where they talk dirty
to her so it was people always say he
cheated on her and I'm always like
that's her [ __ ] job
because everyone has a different
definition of cheating and like their
own people say if you go to the strip
club and you have a girlfriend you're
cheating yeah literally because I was at
a bachelor party for my buddy well
that's what I'm saying like it depends
on that but they are actly as if he was
gonna start a relationship with this
girl I think it depends on who you
represent yourself as yes he's this
family man then it's like oh I can't
believe it but if it was Bobby Lee I
understand that's it you're like wait he
only messaged her that he wants to for
her but you gotta start off representing
yourself as a scumbag exactly that's why
I like that they never have any light
[ __ ] YouTube drama about us cuz we
create our own drama yeah yeah
you can't Jabba me when I draw myself
well I know if the wife didn't like that
then you know that's what I'm saying I'm
just saying I think they painted him to
be like this just terrible
he's just guy he's a little perversion
to him dude's been in a like a year and
a half doghouse yeah for sending
messages his chickens like yo like it's
so yeah of course that was I agree that
that's not not not dope but like damn
see that's the reason why you don't do
family shows it ruin your life well yeah
especially if that's not you that's not
you if that's not really you it's so
tough man like imagine the Blue's Clues
guys getting busted for child porn is
okay it's like damn dude right exactly
I think shaycarl should probably punch
his wife in the face so now there's
something else to get mad at him about
and you forget about the whole camera
thing
that's part you should be in PR that's
acting I'm not saying it was right I'm
just saying I thought that people kind
of crucified him a lot tip a little
harder than night whatever David say I'm
agreement thank you
oh that's ear you're bad David here but
I'm a little bit worried about that so
so what about the Mormon Crips his name
is spelled fi8 he looks the as typical
Tongan as possible yes yeah
CL probably probably just seal our
Tongans as tall as among guys they're
big they're like the original Polynesian
young is a huge man he's 25 it's very
nice except he's like 6 5 to 8 years it
looks like you're a nice young man half
smile he does look older than 20 but
they just have really great bone density
yes they will [ __ ] you up yeah so he
attacked a witness or he attacked the
person that was what do you think would
happen I don't know yeah so let me show
you guys the clip the crooked shut him
up the reason why it's neat and it's
Muse now cuz this happened back in 2014
but it's news now because this clip was
recently surfaced and people were like
wow maybe he was trying to stick it in
his neck so then they can't talk anymore
oh yeah yeah then he's gonna go away for
attempted murder like but when I heard
her say whatever that person was ratting
him out for that would have probably
been worse than attempted murder or his
racketeering he's protecting the group
maybe yeah
these anti Rico we got it another game
[Music]
you know it's pretty this just looks
like Taiwanese politics yeah everyone's
jumping tables [ __ ] beat each other
yeah it's hilarious I will say this
these people have probably seen a lot of
[ __ ] because they're still in their
[ __ ] chairs and they're like oh look
at that guy he's still in this chair she
was very fast she was [ __ ] ready what
did he just for a moment she was like
you know just like scratching your nose
I thank you oh my god
yeah you could see her pull out the gun
quickly yeah she's that's crazy how she
didn't even shoot anybody else okay
I'll be like oh [ __ ] I gotta make sure
I'm not shooting all the people yeah so
then that's why I'm as soon as they
heard the gunshots like there are some
people over here like they got under
their dad he took the pen from his
lawyer yeah he's a [ __ ] da God from
Marshall good this will get up like
nothing tip your hair
Oh what if that boy went through hit the
other guys crazy
didn't land it was handed up like going
like this for actually the other way he
went like this and then like he landed
this way so he didn't get him it's
interesting cuz I thought oh gee yeah he
wasn't as he would have been a GP yeah
this is what I'm saying people in their
head are a lot faster than they think
they are and that wasn't that fun
because it wasn't that fast by bit you
in his mind he was like BAM but it was
he should have trained hurdles if you do
hurdle training yeah didn't you would
have hopped over that thing like nothing
maybe he says something really mean like
you yeah yeah what's this guy's defense
maybe he said some mean [ __ ] yeah like
they were he was the witness was like
the witness was like so
the man was peeing in public and his
dick was really small by the way he's
like oh hell no [ __ ] dick is big or
he's like he's like we me and the
gentlemen were in a sexual relationship
was very very physical very physical
yeah he's like oh I will say this he
likes it in the butt it's an objection
and he's like he's like what does it
have to do with it being hard as the
judges like overruled like cheering yeah
what about it being hard [ __ ] that's not
what you said last night you know if I
was and this guy is gay and I watch this
tape now I would learn to not grab a pen
and just overrun the woman Marshall and
take her gonna shoot the guy you can't
tell what the Marshall is you can have
in those court cases take cap off pen
and it you gotta be good look like she
was wearing just normal no cuz Marshalls
in a courtroom
they're like FBI agents so there weren't
a suit but then they'll have their badge
on there underdog that's what that
taught me that's what this video Tommy
killed him is to take the gun from
someone and then blast I know is he
really thinking did he actually think
that he was gonna
make it and kill her coz mix I think he
was so enraged dude I think so
you're so enraged that he's like [ __ ] it
I just gotta get rid of this [ __ ]
this dude that's in cuffs to do this you
know it's like yikes come on man dude if
I what I mean I follows that lady though
like they probably is probably an
international news story because I have
been on my phone like what happened just
like Oh sex to my wife it woulda just
been one of these things like here's a
flower arrangement for my wife right or
it's like my wife couldn't find their
keys and I told her they're [ __ ] in
the thing yeah so his family their
family filed the lawsuit saying that
they used excessive force because they
shot him once but then like the first
time like they're saying that they
should just shot him once but they shot
him every time dude there is no mental
like are you kidding me this lady had to
be that fast and had to put him down
like how do you at the same time when
you have a lot of adrenaline you don't
know if the first one got him yeah and
like even if it gets them and if it's
not like here in the video to they're
saying like put the fan down put the pen
down so like he was still writing a note
stop writing a note I love all this like
after start [ __ ] where it's like the cop
shot three times you said yeah that's
good that's not intent to kill because
they're taught to shoot at least six to
eight times to take someone out
completely so three shots is is
basically not enough to to really I mean
well in this case on 100% doesn't matter
yeah but if you're aiming to just kill
someone then yeah it's like six to eight
Wow yeah so then the judge ended up
dismissing that that he's like well case
dismissed
like the judges are saying like no this
marshal day what she needed to do and
you know what the sad thing is like that
family now it's gonna think like the the
system is so corrupt
United mean and they're gonna be one of
those people that are talking about and
we just went out there already those
people because look at
they're sorry oh that's true what do you
do what do you do what does the judge do
after this happens oh he's like we will
have a 15-minute recess no I think they
close it out do they yeah I think they
say like hey well that's reached his
conclusion that in the next group comes
in so I would not something similar like
this but I was called actually went to
jury duty once and I was I was
handpicked to be one of the jury duty
people whatever they're called the jury
jurors were so close
jury and and as we were waiting outside
to enter the courtroom they said oh it's
already been settled you guys are all
dismissed
whoa I got it that's tired yeah I mean
it kind of I do want to say this though
rest in peace sir because I don't want
you to kill me if you guys ever come to
LA I don't live in LA I live somewhere
else yeah I just no matter why it just
sucks to be in this position
[Music]